America loves
grapes I'm Jason 2 J Jennings I was a
football legend but once you reach the
Mountaintop of greatness everybody wants
to see you fall the problem is that
you're a selfish prick who's impossible
to work with man you you heral and
Kumar looking I'm through
with this
[Applause]
karma is a b you plad guilty
to charges of speeding and damage to
city property I'm recommending community
service with the Long Beach Recreations
department the I thought I was
getting like some Martha Stewart kind of
treatment from the of the sea
the I am your new head coach you flashed
up Blues he used a fake penis to cheat
on drug test I War one of these you
booger no watch it
Jason
Kare Jason I've been trying to get back
in touch with you for years I know
you've been thinking about me and I know
you've been trying to get in touch with
me cuz that pretty much right you just
put a gun in my head relax Jay the
safety was on oh no it wasn't on what
imagine that before we can be the best
we got to master the
fundamentals hey dog you ever touch a
titty before that's your titty you got
to hold it tight do I have consent of
touching the titty you got my consent
okay I like the titty thing keep that
I like the titty
thing JJ how you liking this game coach
I don't know what I'm doing do you
remember what you were like when you
showed up freshman year you were paining
in the ass I don't want nobody nothing
sound just like me if you really want to
win a game stop pushing away your
team let's
go it looks like a black princess layup
new Jes for y'all does his jersey say
titties underdogs on three underdogs on
me one 2 3 what's my
name pretty boy you missing pass after
pass you got on all this sweet ass
next time you come out here acting like
a fake ass rapper we going to kick your
ass off the field stop acting like you
got an album coming
out